Welcome to AB testing podcast your modern testing podcast your hosts Alan
Hi, and Brent not Brent will be here to guide you through topics on testing leadership
Agile and anything else that comes to mind now on with the show. Hey everyone back for AB testing
It's just me s for spy. Don't call me Alan and
Brent is still on hiatus. He is I believe he's massaging Satya Nadella's feet right now
And so instead I have my good friend Tim here Tim. Say hi. Hello everybody
Alright, so Tim's gonna fill in and and play the role of Brent, which means I'm gonna yell it in make fun of him
Are you ready for it Tim? Yeah, and I may I may use your dead name because I'm not used to calling you spy yet
Okay, well get used to I don't it's so I apologize up front
It's our people learn people learn doesn't help that my little name take at the bottom here has my government name on it
If you're just tuning into the podcast
This is our second one after I took four and a half month hiatus to go walk from Mexico to Canada
Had a blast and along the way my name changed. It's no longer the old name that you may know me by it's now spy
And that's who I am to anybody met me on the trail. So
For those you one of you listen listening
One of the three did meet on the trail and everybody else just learned to call me my new name
Good meme posted on our our slack group this week one of the three dot slack comm you can get it
From modern testing org. It's the one with the astronaut
Looking at the earth and they're the one with a gun behind him
But they said is Alan spy and said it was like it always has been
Which is true. It's great. It's wonderful. So Tim, thanks for thanks for being here to be my punching bag
Yeah, yeah, I'm
as you all know, I'm unemployed and
Happily unemployed right now, even though I'm kind of looking for I'm not kind of kind of I mentioned this last time
I'm not going to the whole big thing. I'm looking for a job. I'm being selective because I don't want to have a job or
They don't care about people or software
In fact, I just talked to a former colleague of mine
about a lot of this and
anyway, as mentioned last week, my job would probably come through my network versus
LinkedIn but I thought I'd well first let me check in with you. See how you're doing. What's up? What's new? How's life?
Oh life's going good. You know on that, you know looking for a job my
Spawn is also looking for a job despite my best
ability to talk him out of going into the same tech field that I'm in he decided that was he's gonna get his degree in and
as
anybody who's tried to get a job in the
Cascadia Northwest in the tech, it's up and down right now. So it's a weird world
Yeah, and and he cut he's getting he's he's worked service while he was doing jobs
so while he's doing school, excuse me and
so a
Opportunity through his network came up to work at at a place that's pretty close to where he's living now
So, oh, that's cool. That's cool. Well, nice nice
meanwhile, here I am playing pickleball with the retirees and
Going to the gym and goofing off. So yeah, awesome. So I want to talk a little bit about
my experiences on the social media platform known as LinkedIn, oh boy and
Because I thought I should spend some time there because I'm looking for a job
It turns out that LinkedIn isn't a very good place to look for a job splice place for recruiters to look for people
Oh, yeah, I get like three a week it usually from Florida and Atlanta areas
Yeah, I I don't live there. I don't it's weird. I don't I don't even I'll move there for the right job
but I I end up scrolling LinkedIn and I haven't been on Twitter for
Years, I never deleted my account
But I haven't been there or X as it's called and I feel like LinkedIn has turned into when people left that platform
LinkedIn to kind of came the place where I don't know where they
Hung out instead. Oh
Yeah, I can see that there's a lot of random weird posts
So I mean I deleted my Twitter account with a vengeance when oh good for you
I am bought his but bought out the company and
Weird weird weird. So what happens is usually once a day sometimes twice a day. I will make it through
To
Sometimes three pages of scrolling I get discussed in closed LinkedIn until the next day
Like there's a lot of the job shows up there. It's a lot
Unhealthy five minutes of my day
But what did I see I'm seeing
Like I've also actively unfollowed people. I know I'm creating an echo chamber, but I don't have time for dumbness
Who does yeah, so apparently a lot of people in this country too, but I honestly don't
So what I found interesting that we're gonna go off in a couple different directions here is
Tim and I both have a fair amount of experience in
Good project management agile project management moving stuff along. I'm a galvanizer. I love to get stuff moving along
Boy the internet's weird the post I saw I'm not gonna bring it up. I can't remember the so I won't quote it
you can't find it but
Someone was saying like ask the question and they were trying to be I think people on LinkedIn
They're they're trying to they're just trying to get engagement because they get their ego gets boosted by getting a bunch of oppressions and comments
So maybe they're basically they're trolling I think or they're dumb or both and I can't tell
Yeah, they said something like can you even do agile without a good without a scrum master?
Yes, yes, you can I've been doing it for two years
well the point I like to bring up is that
Scrum has been around as a framework and this is I'm gonna get on a soapbox here scrum has been around as a framework
Since before the agile manifesto agile manifesto came out and a bunch of people said oh
But we can we can't we can't ship software without a framework
Oh, here's one little work and what 90% of the teams do was scrum
And again all the roles you don't need a scrum master to do scrum. You don't need
You
God you don't need most of it. What it did was it gave teams a nice little way to do mini waterfalls
back to back to back to back
Yeah, yeah, and
And there are so many teams lost in the I need to have a person in this role telling me what to do
And making sure we do these rituals. I mean if I recall from looking at scrum 20 years ago
A lot of these air quote rituals aren't even called rituals in the scrum original scrum guide doesn't matter. I don't care
That where people get lost in agile. I'm gonna shut up and give some opinions where people get lost in agile is
They focus on iteration which is not the goal of agile instead of adaptability which is
Yeah, yeah, and you're catching me raw because I spent the first three days of this week in our
Software programs
Program increment and we're gonna talk about program increment. Yeah. Yeah, we just did
I will get on a taller soapbox, but I'm gonna let you finish. Yeah, we did this to their planning for the next 13 weeks
This last three days. Yeah, we have longer. We have longer program increments because we're
more
Synced up with our government customer. So and they do things on quarters. So we do things on quarters
Yeah, I agree. I've been doing scrum for two years without a scrum master
I was originally the scrum master when our
stuff switched over to agile or and you know, specifically safe agile, which is
Agile safe stands for I don't want to do agile. Yeah, it really does because what we did in the first
Ten twelve years. I was on this program was
waterfall that was just what we did and
Because of the team that I work on they kind of just sort of left us alone
You know, we had we would get maybe one maybe two
Tasks assigned to us. But you know since my team is an operations operating system development team
That one thing
Contained a lot of stuff. So they left us alone now
We switched over to agile and it seems like nickel and diming to death, you know
Because we have to do every single thing
But they don't understand the concept of story points
Because they've just assigned an hour value to story points at management level and it's just a nightmare
Yeah, that's just that's the biggest drawback with story points is and
Is the yeah, somebody will do that and then they're then they're ruined
yeah, and what's been that way for about two years and
That's that's my biggest
The biggest thing I banged my head against it's the you know, I this I know this task is it take you 40 minutes
but you got to put one story point on it because
That's as slow as we go story points are integers. We just got so many other people that try to use a decimalized story points
I'm like, well, that's that's that's just that's just waterfall
You just tell me how many minutes it's gonna be and we can drop the whole pretense of points
The story point is a measure of complexity not a measure of time
Exactly and if if the bean counters get involved in a different way, it's difficult and the challenge let me talk about two things
One is I've never had scrum masters. I believe my development leads are responsible for in their projects
However, they want to they can use scrum. They can use waterfall. They can use some made-up thing
I don't care dead leads are in charge of their project management now
I'm gonna save my safe rant. Am I gonna save my safe rant? I'm gonna save the safe rant
All right for for a minute
The challenge with agile adaptable and
Story points don't matter. I don't care what they are. You want to you work on things until they're done and
The challenge is you can have a like there's a whole no estimates
I call a culture a no estimates movement along the agile community saying predicting the future is impossible. We're not gonna do it
No, we're not gonna give you estimates because
Things are done when they're done and we're gonna work on and work on them in the best way
That's not really fair either because stakeholders whether it's management or customers or other teams
They kind of want to know when things can are gonna get done
So it's not the no estimates thing really isn't fair. So I'll give you it on that but
The idea is is you break down like I always require my teams to give estimates when things are gonna get done
But I give them some leeway. I said there's a great a fact
There's one of my favorite books is this Hubbard book called how to measure anything and then he just came out with a new book
Sort of a
Iteration on that called how to measure anything in project management
But the idea isn't how to measure anything as you measure on confidence levels
so I have my teams give p50 estimates or
sometimes an estimate like what's your
what's your
90% range between this state and this state they both work and Hubbard uses them both and then they have permission to be
Wrong, but they also have permission to learn from that and that what they learn is they have to break stuff down into smaller
Pieces they can get done and over time if you do that over and over those dates can get more and more accurate if you
Tie if the bean counters, I'm gonna call the pointy hair bosses being casual
if they get tied to
Picking a date when something's going to get or picking how many hours something get done do the math and say, okay
I'm gonna have my widget by next Friday
It's there's too much uncertainty in software and as you know on the technical side we can break that down when there's uncertainty
We break it down farther. We try and make it simple by breaking down the problem into smaller problems and
Over time we can get better at picking when those things are going to get done
But there's always are going to be outliers things that take longer things that take shorter and
the minute you pick a two a
Story point of five and actually get it done in realize it's easy and get done in an hour
They're gonna think all the five should be done in an hour. So as as a PO
How do you deal with?
Tell me more about how you deal with story points and the estimates and people expecting on when stuff's gonna get done
Yeah. Yeah. Well, so our my team's initial problem lies in being an
Operating as a Kanban team in a sea of scrum team. So we've got eight teams on our program
two of them are Kanban and ever so everybody else is planning to
What sprint is this gonna be done in and we just don't work that way
So when we do planning we just kind of
Shuffle all the things into the bin. So we're like, okay, we're not over in any sprint
We're you know, we have a confidence of four
We're gonna meet plan and then you know the next day we go and shuffle everything around
but when I get my devs to write stories or
Feature that they're that they had aren't quite ready to write stories for but stories. I try to contain them to a
complexity of one
Three or five if it's one, it's super easy meaning you could probably do three or four in a day
If it's three, it's medium hard
It's probably gonna take you a couple days and if it's five
It's probably gonna take you most of a week to get done
If you have a story that's over a five which is allowed in in all the different frameworks
Trainings that I've been shoved down my throat
If it's over five you need to replant that into multiple things because that you know
If you have a seven or twelve point story that doesn't tell you when it's gonna get done
It tells you you don't know when you're gonna get done
It tells you when you don't you don't know exactly right and go ahead and finish and we have to meet
Contractual dates so we've got to kind of work backwards from those dates and figure out
When are we gonna get all the little bits done so that we can meet this date?
For code cutoff and delivery
But
Once threes and fives, it's all I want to see the occasional twos fine
But you know, I don't want to see anything over a five for my team
Yeah, and that's good. And again, I always let my teams choose whatever method they want to use attract set
But they must give a date with the confidence level now over a year a year. I tracked
we delivered like a hundred and eighty different projects and a project is something that delivers customer value in some way and
I tracked
Original estimate the actual delivery date for every single one of those and a bunch of other data
What I found is gonna back up what you say completely
Anything from one to two weeks was on time like 80 to 90 percent of the time
Somewhere in there like pretty accurate went two weeks or less pretty accurate four weeks and beyond was all over the map
Ridiculous long because that means there's a length when you cannot figure out how much work there is to do and
Interestingly when people often thought something's gonna be easy they put like it also be done by Friday
It always took like twice as long
So it's and which is fine. They learn from that and they got better and over time
You want to just give people room to fail so they can target in on these things
So you want is predictability for your partners your customers, etc
But you have to give them room to screw that up now
There's something else I was gonna say and then my brain farted
That happens. Yeah, well age
Crap, what was it?
Delivery teams blah blah blah, it'll come back to me, but I
I just I don't I don't get why people are. Oh, let me go. It was combo
It's about combo. So combo is great because you're tracking
And again for an interrupt driven team. It's the right way to do it versus try and plan those things out
You want to be able to focus on
You know a minute a finite number of things at once and as Brenton I always say focus on on
Finishing not on doing
so
So you don't have your whole like I was working with the team once they're doing Kanban and they had
And the thing with Kanban is a it's a flowchart basically and you can understand where the bottlenecks are things get stuck
In one column for too long. You know, okay, what's the problem here?
And the problem could be work isn't broken down enough
That's probably where I was going before is we taught people to break down their work over time
That makes it more predictable
Especially if you can deliver if you have a big feature you're gonna deliver for customers
You can deliver part of it in two weeks to give them some value and the rest in two more weeks or even spread out longer
That's so so much better and more predictable and honestly
You're gonna get feedback customers faster than doing something that takes six eight ten weeks now with Kanban
working with the team once they had a big bottleneck in the development thing because they had a bunch of
three four and five like like longer projects in there and
they kept on upping the limit so common as a concept of a work-in-progress a whip and
They had like nine a limit of nine in that development and they had nine developers
So there's no way for anybody to help each other out. Everybody was stuck on getting their thing done
It's if you use in Kanban, I'm just curious in your experience here as well
The beauty of Kanban is you can use it to figure out where the bottlenecks are and and optimize around them
So so true. How does your team do that?
usually
The way our team is a little it operates is a little unusual for what you call it a scrum team
Doing Kanban in the midst of a bunch of other teams doing scrum in that we try to
resort to doing most of the planning between myself the product owner and
my second in charge the program manager and
when we have
Planning which is what we did the first three days of this week
It'll just be me and him doing most of the work now
We've had a lot of work run up to it, you know getting stories and whatnot in ready in place, but
for the most part
We try to figure out and work one-on-one with with the engineers prior to our planning
meetings and
figure out what they think they can get done and
Plan it out accordingly, then we have to lay out our plan according to the rest of the
The rest of our program groups all beings
Scrum teams and we'll lay it all out and we'll know that it's good things are gonna get shuffled around a little bit
and one of the things that we do as
Because we know our team is gonna get stuff changed a lot. We run on a higher
Pop-up budget than a lot of other teams is a lot of the other teams will do like 15 20 percent of their
Capacity reserved for pop-up work and we typically run about 35 percent because we know that stuff's gonna pop up for us
And we typically fill that
35% budget every time
And a lot of times that happens within like two weeks after the start of the of the new scrum increment
Because the customer changed their mind or some new requirement came down and being on the operating system team
You've got to have you're basically the lowest part things have to get working in your environment for anybody up
The line can do their work. One of the reasons I prefer Kanban over any of the other models
Is because it allows for that
It's I mean if you look at I mean so many people who there's so many scrum masters and scrum folks who are
Induit they get to take them and equate scrum with agile idiots
They don't even they're even read the documentation on it. What you know, originally it said that
And I haven't looked at this in years. Maybe decades if you end up adding
You know, I heard was any or an increment if you're if you're adding work stop replan start over
That that burn up is hard and now and you can put a buffer in there
Which I don't which I don't particularly like it works
But if you're going to be interrupt driven either either don't do scrum or
Do scrum on a one-week increments increments so that pop-up work comes you can plan it into the thing starting the next Monday
Yeah, yeah, don't do it. Don't do a four-week sprint. If you know, you're gonna have interrupts coming in
Yeah, our team is
specifically
interrupt driven mainly because we
Don't know we've kind of got gained a reputation as as
Solution fixers, you know people come to us with their with the problems that their team's working on and so that's why our
Budget for sort of what we call pop-ups pop-up work is so high
Because we know we're gonna fill it. We know it's gonna come along and
We'll just have to rearrange things
Yeah, well it makes sense. It sounds like and I'm gonna rant on safe for a second now
Then we're gonna talk about how to fix it. So
It's a scaled agile framework for enterprise enterprise
Yeah, it is a way for enterprises. So when the pointy hair boss decides he wants to do agile, but he's afraid of it
He can do safe and not really do agile. So
Brent I'm glad he's not here because Brent actually is certified and safe as well
And I yeah, I have a scrum master and a PO certification. I
Yeah, so
Let's say it's a big waterfall framework wrapped around
Wrapped around agile not necessarily scrum. Although those teams do these product increments, which are scrum sessions of two to four weeks and
It's it's really not agile at all. If you go back to the manifesto
It's you know, I'll skip the individuals interactions, but it's working software customer collaboration and responding to change
those are the things they value the most and
When you are delivering things at the end of a 13 week product, how long is your PI?
It's one quarter. So 13 weeks. We typically have a
we've got
Usually four sprints of two weeks and then a longer fifth sprint which is supposed to be your you know
Where you're supposed to be learning new things, but we never have time for that
People are people are finishing up all the stuff
They didn't get done the other sprints because they didn't do them right in the first place. Yeah
Every team over promises and those things. It's a big mess. Yeah, it is
It is it's not agile it's it's it's I think it's a and we did
My last company used safe and I immediately pulled my team out of safe completely didn't make sense for a platform team
but it
Was actually done even more horribly and it was a big bureaucratic meeting fest
I wish I had that I wish I had that option
but I am you know, despite being in in this job for 20 years and the and the industry for 30 I'm still just
Senior developer. I'm not I didn't I had zero desire to go into management. So
that really wasn't my option, but so here's the challenge and
Deliveries hard. We're so we should not try it. I think is a message. That's not the message
I want to turn this into a leadership conversation
Good good. I have like I think again do not mention where you work and and but
What is it like like how do you communicate the challenges like, you know safe doesn't work
You're you're you're working around it in a bunch of different ways and I'm sure you're not the only person
I'm sure across your organization people going this is a big mess. There has to be a better way. Why aren't we doing it?
What is that like and and and why do you think in your case your management doesn't get it?
Well, I think mainly the management
I think mainly the management
That I want and I won't talk about specifically my managers
Okay, the manager I have is talking generalities generalities because the manager I have now is
they were an engineer prior to becoming a manager and they wanted to be a manager because
The manager previous to that was an engineer but didn't want to be a manager and they kind of tricked him into it
but uh
so they understand our current manager understands the
Ins and outs of the troubles that we have with with agile and safe specifically
I think it was the reason that our organization uses it
I think it was dictated by the customer they because they wanted to be able to integrate
with something that they're already using they're already familiar with so
I know that our customer has accounts in our
system so they can check on progress of stories and
Things like that from from their end without having to call somebody up and ask them
And i'm, not really sure how you work into a scrum type or an agile
Environment in a in a company as large as ours and uh and be able to survive
But like I said that my first 10 years there were
We didn't use agile we didn't use
Scrum we didn't use any of that stuff
We just kind of you know everybody got together on a semi-weekly basis and said what do we got to do this week?
and boom off we went
And our team usually only had to go like once a month because you know, we knew all the things that we needed to do
Uh, we didn't want to waste a lot of time explaining it to people who didn't really understand
I want to ask a point of clarification
So you have a a customer team that wanted to know when things were going to get done
Correct and the solution was safe
well
As I as I mentioned our our customer is the government so
If you have a government contract, you kind of don't have a lot of negotiating
Space and obviously I was not involved with any of that
I came onto this program after it was already like five years in
operation
Yeah, I I get it
I guess it would be a little farther up the chain where somebody would
Like my question is when somebody tells me they need something I would say imagine you had that tell me what it looks like
and
they're
You know in my view again, I haven't had government customers
I would think and i'm sure you think it's too there and it wasn't your decision to make but surely there had to be
A better solution
Oh, yes. Yeah
and part of the part of the problem I see
Over the decades i've been on this is that
The leadership or the mid-level leadership of our customer changes out every year year and a half two years because
people are moving from
You know people get into government positions and they either stay there for 40 years until they're ready to retire or get
You know kicked out because they're too old or they change jobs as often as they can to keep
climbing the ladder and so that's what we see a lot and
And uh, it's just you know, you don't have any consistency from the customer side either
There is a book
um, I don't know if you've read this, uh
It's i'm gonna keep it's a really good book called orbiting. I'll show you the picture here called orbiting the giant hairball
Good lord, it's about um, it's a corporate fool's guide to surviving with grace
and
One thing it sounds like you've done pretty well, which um
I've done well and not done well in this for is when you're in
A sickening bureaucracy is how do you survive the author is this guy is artist who got a job at hallmark
And how he learned to still be kind of keep his integrity as a freewheeling artist and also
work with him
What is a surprisingly bureaucratic and political company?
now
I wonder
uh, and
Obviously people are still employed and they're capable
About I want to work one of the stories just talk to like right before we talk talk to an old colleague of mine
and they were
challenged because
They had had three different managers in the last year
And none of them really understand what what they're they're their organization did
and spend a lot of their time just explaining like what they did and the value it brought and
Depending on
You know
In most cases they didn't really care
It was just
You know so many manager were about people in power versus understanding what's going on
and
if you look at the literature on what
drives employee engagement what makes a good organization or
What makes a job miserable is the opposite of that is people just want to know that they want feedback
They want to know their manager cares about them in their career and they want to know why their job is important
and I wonder in
A situation where you're following a framework and you're kind of stuck in it
Maybe you find ways to work around and orbit the giant hairball. Maybe it's just frustrating
but
What's it like? I want to understand a little bit more what it's like when you know, there's a better way
But you're doing it the way you're told
Anyway, like what's that like for you and the folks you work with?
well
Obviously, we know there's a better way. Well
For us a better way and that was you know to be basically left unsupervised and off the leash and we would get the
High high. Yeah, because everybody on our team is an engineer
Some of us got voluntold into these agile positions
and so now I spend upwards of like
70 percent of my time doing planning and
Talking to the other engineers and making sure everything goes right
When I got into engineering because I like doing the engineering part of it
but
as for
Support from above now in in the time that i've been on this this team like
17 plus years i've had seven different managers
And some of them were really good managers because they came from engineering and others
Didn't and you could tell which ones were and the ones that weren't
Typically didn't last on our ass as our team's manager for very long and
What I find that my team needs
is
To be able to just put their heads down do their work
And at the end of the increment we're going to come out with what you've asked for
And again, our team is very pop-up driven, but that doesn't cover everybody on the team
That's usually like two or three people on the team because they're
The big brains you know big brain on brad so they need them to go work this
emergent problem on in the labs or an emergent problem on another team
And so they'll jump over to that stuff. It sounds like you're orbiting the giant hairball pretty well
We are we are so
We kind of just
Work around it. We go. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. The giant hairball is there and we acknowledge it
But we're not going to get hung up by it. We're just going to kind of work around it
and until
Somebody says hey, why aren't you?
Why are you trekking through the hairy forest like everyone else is we go? Well because you guys want us to meet our
Release deadlines. So we just kind of give you the lip service. Yes, we're doing that and we just kind of go
Do our own thing anyway
Yeah, makes sense
and we do that by sacrificing one or two of the senior engineers to
Doing all the paperwork as opposed to having to have everybody do all that stuff now
Like I said, I get some of my engineers to write their own stories
But oftentimes it just falls to me and the program manager to write all the story work
Because we're the ones that's spending all the time in meetings with their teams and management and the customer
So we kind of know what what's going on in the overall
And I just want to let my engineers do engineering and not have to worry so much about this
Framework paperwork nightmare. Yeah, I mean and I say paperwork
I say paperwork, but it's all online. I know what you mean. It's all it's all policy and bureaucracy. So
Uh, no, I get it. I get it
It's not like you're doing a good job navigating the team through that
I tend to get frustrated in those things because when i'm oh, yeah. Yeah
I
It's not that I even get mad and tell people I don't go raging, you know go raging and there's a this is wrong
It's stupid, but I do want to
push people and brent brent is you know
more than one time referred to me as a change agent, I like to make change happen and I
I believe in a line from leadership online books on the floor over there. I won't grab it
leadership is disappointing people at a level they can absorb and
you know when i'm in those situations I
want to push things I want to change things but and you
I
Also want to push people a little out of their comfort zone, but not so much they get all freaked out
And it's a little game because everybody gets like sometimes I can push a little people freak out sometimes push a lot and they don't
You have to kind of read that as you go along, but so many times
like uh
I mean, it's the right thing to do
Uh, I just thinking I put reflection on my last job when there was somebody I could push like let me just touch my
Microphone barely and they go hey stop stop. I can't handle the change. It's too much
Like dude
It's just it's it's sad
so um
But that's that's one of the things I like about hearing your work stories when we get together outside of this
arena and
You've got a lot of leadership qualities that I wish that I had in myself
Uh, not for the point of being uh management or a vp or anything
But I think that if I was a better leader than my engineers could be better engineers
It sounds like you're doing a pretty good job
I try
And I think we bring different leadership skills to different leadership situations
I
I do not like stagnant organizations
I believe if we should build organ it sounds like you're doing this building organization people have an opportunity to learn something every day
Where they can do their best to work where they are engaged in what they're doing and if they're stuck in
You know
How much work are your engineers getting done during six hours of meetings today? Not very much, right, right
and the downfall of of
Of your teaching your engineers to be better engineers and to learn new things is
Right now I'm I work with a team of ten five of them are senior engineers myself included and
five of them are
Less than five years in the field completely. In fact some two of them are like right out of college
And in the last three years, we've had we've gone through one two three
We've gone through four right out of college engineers. They come on they stay for six months eight months
and they learn a lot and they're just becoming productive and
Out the door. They're off to either another program within the company or off to another company and
It doesn't make me want to
work with the engineers and make them better any less, but that is one of the pitfalls of
of
Helping to make your your junior engineers
senior lines are we and
I'll tell a story from our last company after I asked this question
but uh
Is there less turnover given the current market situation where there aren't as many jobs for them to go to?
uh, well
The two newest members on our team are less than six months
on the team
so
and that that was one was a replacement and
One was a new, you know a team expansion that we've been screaming for for several years
I think I start I told on the podcast once but in my last
company
I was in some management or leadership meeting and they were
Someone from hr was bragging about the fact that turnover was the lowest it had been in the last, you know several years
Completely failing to recognize the context that there were no jobs for them. Yeah, yeah in the world. There's nothing to do
So
Uh, I I I do worry a lot there
Um, there was something else i was going to ask about this, but maybe I don't know
Like do you like it?
Do you like what you're doing? If I didn't like it, I wouldn't have been doing it for the last 17 18 years
um, and
I get you know, we've been talking about leadership and
planning and all of that but again
The days that that just screamed by i'm like, oh man, it's time to go home already
Those are the days that I have some tough engineering problem I get to work on
And those even though they're farther apart than they were in my beginning days here
Those are the days that really make it for me. They make it worth it
Uh when I get to see the younger engineers go, ah, and they learn some new concept
And uh things get better for them that that's another thing that makes it worth it. So
Um, it's kind of it's kind of one of the reasons that i'm looking to
Retire and go into teaching, uh from this job
um
Is i'd like that being able to teach the young minds and give them new stuff
Yeah, that's why I want to stay in software. I want to teach young minds and give them new stuff
Yeah, well, i'm
Yeah, i'm 30 plus years in the software software, uh computers hardware networking. That was like
My hobby when I was younger
And so I went oh if this is my hobby I can make it my job and so I made it my job without any sort
Of formal training completed degrees after I already had the job
To get the degrees that would allow me to continue to hold on to the job
And uh now I want to go teach the things that are my hobbies now which are
Decidedly not computer and software
Related. Yeah, that's super cool. Um, speaking of hobbies and and stuff
I
On the last podcast, uh what we did last week. We were talking about andreas and I think andreas suggested this is
um should
Index like the transcripts of all of the ab testing episodes
Yeah, yeah, I was bored
Oh goodness a script to download all the mp3s from anchor where we're hosted was pretty easy. They came down pretty quickly
um, so there's like
This is episode 221. I think but there's like we did about I did some
Bonus episodes that kind of there's like there's like 240 some episodes are downloaded and then uh
Use whisper ai and just use the python library for it and I went through
Because I had time
I went ahead and picked a more efficient model so I could get better transcripts
So I used whisper ai to trant to transcribe
every single podcast
into just a raw text dump as well as um
Some formats that are used by closed captioning systems. I did that took about 24 hours to run. It was kind of cool
Yeah, yeah
I mean kind of it's a it's a macbook air but it's an m4
So i'm not sure if well still you're talking about 200 plus hours that you processing. That's pretty good. Yeah, so
um
That's a 24 hours process took a day
Well of the of the the podcast. Oh, yeah of the pot. Yeah, yeah of yeah
Math there's like 240 hours of podcasts. Yeah, I went through all those I have transcripts and then
I think i'm gonna put them into notebook llm or something
I could but what I did first was I wrote a little a little python search engine
Just I globbed together all the text files and I can see the beast man
Just gonna feed them into an llm. Of course, I have to but for for now i'm not
But I can do things like like I can pick like principal five or project management or scrum and I can find
How many how many episodes which episodes that term was mentioned in?
And how many times did that episode it was mentioned?
Wow
So i'm i'm gonna do one right now pick. Um, let me find my my command prompt
Um, where's my?
Is that my thing?
No
I forgot what I called it
Okay, pick a word pick a word
um
Oh good lord
Good lord. No. No, that's not the word. But you know, it goes right on the spot pick a word
We're gonna we're gonna do this live. This is great
Uh, all right ai because we were just oh my god
Yeah, i'm worried
Yeah, i'm worried worried for you because my comment was I was scrolling through the the old episodes just uh this morning
And I noticed that a lot of them. Okay, you're gonna love this
Episodes with at least one mention ten
I don't believe total mentions across those episodes a thousand
That seems a little small but okay, it seems like it would be more than ten, right?
but maybe it didn't come out as
I bet it didn't come out
Yeah, something's weird they might not be talking they might not be counting like when you say artificial intelligence or lom
instead
What if I say gen ai?
Just to make that even better closer. Uh, that's a lot. Let me scroll up here. Holy crap gen ai
Still 10 episodes, but 103 mentions
um anyway, it well I I didn't say testing because that would have been a
That would have sank that shows up in the intro because the intro gets transcribed as well
so, uh, yeah, not gonna do that, but I searched for whiskey that's like 10 of those or eight of those and
It's fun. I'm not sure what i'm gonna do with it, but it's there. Yeah, it'd be interesting to see the uh,
Increase in frequency of stuff like hiking because you know, you've been a hiker for a long time
But there's all kinds of stuff we're talking about it and probably I should just because they're just text files
I should maybe think about uploading all those text files. We have a um
uh
I forget what it's called. I haven't been to github in a while, but we have a we have a slot
We have a github repository for
The uh for the podcast. Okay, I just put them up there and then
You know at some point it has all the episodes up through last week
At some point I could just you know, do it with the rest of them. I gotta think about it
um, yeah, there's something there and uh
There was on slack. There was a great quote
It said
I'm gonna find out quick here. Um
What was it? There's a german proverb that translates roughly into having is better than needing
So now you have the transcripts when the time comes you will know what to do with them
So I have them i'll know when I find them
uh, I find that uh, I find that to be
The hoarder's mindset man. I'm telling you because and i'm not i'll i'll i'll hoard digitally but um,
Uh, yeah, I well I get that i'm just as bad physically with certain things but digitally
um, I mean I
I have weaned myself off of it in that I don't have a large
storage area network
filer in the house anymore, but
Yeah, I used to used to hold on to stuff for way too long and never got never went back to it
Just it was the having not the needing at that point
Well, I think you can be selective about what you need and well and I am now so it's just
You know which eliminates the need for having a
You know multi-terabyte filer in the house anymore. Yeah, for sure for sure
All right, man. Um
It I think it's probably a good enough place to wrap it up. You know the thoughts on anything else
We want to talk about you know, any shout outs comments. I don't know what to ask you
uh
I don't think so. I mean
That would be of little interest of the two other people who listen the two other people who listen
Hello you two good good to have you here
All right, then well, um
Sorry, you say something no. No, go right ahead. Well, let's uh, let me find my my my fancy buttons here
And uh, let's call it a day. Um, i've been spy
I've been tim. All right. We'll see you next time on the spy somebody else podcast